the 2014 Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine with 1/2 - professor John
Okeefe and the other half jointly -
professors my Brits Moser and Edward
Mercer for their discoveries of cells
that constitute a positioning system in
the brain
this year's laureates have discovered a
positioning system an inner GPS in the
brain that helps us locate our place in
space and helps us navigate our
environments to the press-conference
I got this impression that the audience
was a bit surprised over this choice
well these discoveries don't come out of
the blue it was already in the late
1960s and early 1970s that John Okeefe
made his seminal discovery of the place
cells and 30 years later the Moses
discovered in 2005 discovered the grid
cells so people working in the field and
the broader area of science have been
aware of these discoveries for some time
and aware of the paradigm shifting
nature of their work so I don't know
that it's such a surprise I said well
aware the the will of other Nobel stated
that the prices would be awarded that
those that prefer the greatest benefit
of mankind so how does this prize
fulfill this criteria so that is true
for all of the Nobel prizes and
questions about how we are in the world
how we move in the world how we process
this information has been a subject for
philosophers and psychologists
behavioural ists and experimentalists
for centuries so now we have some
evidence for a network in the brain that
allows us to understand our space in the
world and how we navigate our
environment so I think that's a pretty
big benefit to mankind we know much much
more about how we are in the world
this prize is supposed to be Physiology
or medicine which one would you say is
more applicable here this is a prize for
basic physiology in a field of neural
physiology so we're not on the medical
side yet but really on the basic
fundamental physiology breakthroughs
that make these laureates were the only
real prize well there's really two parts
to this so the first is the discovery by
John Okeefe of the place cells and that
happened in the early 70s and he did
some really remarkable experiments he
was studying the behavior of rats moving
freely in a closed environment and he
was able to put electrodes on the
animals and he could study how they
moved along a route and what he observed
was an activity in a region of the brain
called the hippocampus and when the
animals navigator to move through a
route these cells these placed cells
were excited what he could find was that
it wasn't just one place south but it
was several of these place cells that
work together in a system there were
sort of navigational signposts so to say
you imagine a map near the landmarks
then he could take the rat and he can
move it to a new environment the place
cells were also activated but they were
activated in different combinations
representing that new
environment then he could take the rat
put it back in the initial environment
and the rat had a map it had a memory
could say of the previous route that
police cells fired in the order that
they had initially so the rat had a
cognitive map of its environment the
second part of this discovery comes 30
years later and this was by my buret and
edvard moser they were also studying the
behavior of rats in a closed environment
but they made a larger field for those
animals to move they were also studying
nerve cell activity in a region of the
brain called the internal cortex what
they found was astonishing
when these rats navigated the
environment when they move through the
environment to forage for food they saw
an astonishing activity and when they
drew lines between the visual input of
this activity they found that this
activity represented a hexagon and they
could see that it was a grid-like
structure in other words the rats were
forming a navigational platform and this
was used for moving and for judging
distances so the third part of this is
that understanding that together the
place cells and these grid cells work as
a neural network we have the grid cells
to navigate our environment and we have
the place cells as signposts for us to
help us find our way in the environment
what was this recognized as a
breakthrough at the time it was
astonishing
absolutely so as I mentioned that
breakthrough moments was first of all
the discovery that there were placed
cells
it's one big discovery the second was
that these placed cells worked in
different combinations but the
combination was always the same when the
animal was in the same environment
the third was at this grid like
structure this navigational field
was completely unexpected and then again
putting it together with the circuit
between the internal cortex and
hippocampus understanding this network
for us to code our information on our
place in space and our navigation in
that space try to explain the importance
of this prize to a young person let's
say an 11 year old full of curiosity
right well imagine that your parents
take you on a vacation during the summer
summer break and you're going to go
visit an exciting city like Stockholm ok
and you've never been there before and
so the first thing you do is you take a
map from the hotel and you're gonna help
your family find the Vasa ship so you
have landmarks on the map it could be
the city hall could be the concert house
it could be the palace and the bosses
ship those are like your place cells
because as you pass those landmarks they
recognize your place in space the other
thing you need on that map is longitude
and latitude you need to find a way to
navigate to the Vasa ship in a very
efficient way and the grid cells
function like that navigational chart
they help you judge your distance and
help you find your way
so the remarkable thing is that we don't
need to have the map in our hands we
have these maps in our brain and so I
would describe it that way thanks to our
grid and place cells we don't have to
walk around with a map to help us find
our way each time we visit a city
because we have that map in our house
now if you turn our tents into laureates
who are they well we have John Okeefe
and he was born in the US but he's also
a citizen of the United Kingdom and we
have vibrant and edvard moser who are
Norwegian citizens working in Trondheim
do you know them yourself I have never
met them but I'm very familiar with
their work I'm thinking of the work
called mr. Keith he just like in the 60s
do you know what he's working on now
he's still an active researcher and he
still runs the lab working on technology
advancements to study animal behavior
and also understanding how the brain
still computes its information by
understanding place cells in grid cells
and what makes you so I think it's
really fascinating and a little story
this summer I went to visit my
grandparents cottage in northern
Wisconsin hadn't been there in 30 years
hadn't been there at walls I found
myself at the cottage I could find every
single play play childhood you know
little hideout that I had when I was a
kid I could navigate the environment
remarkably since I hadn't been there in
30 years and I realized thanks to my
place and my grid cells I was able to
find my way and have a great summer
holiday so I think without these cells
we'd have a really hard time to survive
finally has to cook Nobel commit to
being able to get in contact to their
laureates well you're on Hanson had a
conversation with my Brit Moser and she
was in a lab meeting was able to take
his call was delighted had a sit down
have a moment of pause and she of course
wanted the press release in her hand
because she wanted real evidence her
husband just stepped on an airplane to
go to Munich and
he doesn't know so he's sitting on an
airplane and all this is happening
without his knowledge John Okeefe we
found him as well he was at home and he
was very delighted looking forward to
coming to Stockholm in December thank
you so much
thanks again welcome